So today we are going to talk
about another process of lumping
or another process of
discretization what will lead to
the digital abstraction.
So today's lecture is titled
"Go Digital".
So let me begin with a usual
review.
And so in the first lecture we
started out by looking at
elements and lumping them.
For example,
we took an element and said for
the purpose of analyzing
electrical properties let's lump
this element into a single
lumped value called a resistor,
R.
And this led to the lumped
circuit abstraction.
The lumped circuit abstraction
says let's take these elements,
connect them with wires and
analyze the properties of these
using a sort of analysis
technique.
So a set of a methods.
We've looked at the KVL,
KCL method.
Another example of a method we
looked at was the node method.
And of this category there is
one method you should remember,
which you can apply to every
single circuit and it will
simply work, is the node method.
For linear circuits other
methods also apply,
and these include
superposition,
Thevenin method,
and in recitation or in your
course notes you would have
looked at the Norton method.
So that's what we did so far.
So this is a toolkit.
So now you have a utility belt
with a bunch of tools in it,
and you can draw from those
tools.
And, just like any good
carpenter, you know,
the carpenter has to cut a
piece of wood.
He could use a chisel.
He could use a saw.
He could use an electric saw.
And the reason you pay
carpenters $80 an hour in the
Boston region is because they
know which tool to use for what
job.
So what we'll learn today is,
so this was one process of
discretization.
We discretized matter.
This gave us the discipline
here that we decided to follow,
lumped matter discipline,
that moved us from Maxwell's
equations into this new
playground called EECS.
Where all elements looked like
these rinky-dinky little values
like resistors and voltage
sources and so on.
What we'll do today,
if that wasn't simple enough,
let's simplify our lives even
further.
What we're going to do is lump
some more.
So what else can we lump?
We've lumped matter,
so all matter is taken care of.
So what can we lump to make
life even easier?
When in doubt,
if things are complicated,
discretize it or lump it,
right?
So what do you think?
What we will do today is lump
signal values.
So we'll just deal with lumped
values.
And this will lead to the
digital abstraction.
And the related reading is
Chapter 5 of the course notes.
So before we do this kind of
lumping, let me motivate why we
do this.
One reason is to simplify our
lives, but there is no need to
just go around simplifying
things just because we can.
Let's try to see if there are
other reasons motivating the
digital abstraction.
So what I would like to start
with is a simple example of a
analog processing circuit that
you should now be able to
analyze.
So I'm going to be motivating
digital.
So let's start with an analog
circuit that looks like this,
two resistors,
R1 and R2.
And what I'm going to do is
apply a voltage source here,
V1, apply another one here,
V2, and make this connection.
And let me call this voltage V
nought and call this my output.
This voltage with respect to
ground node, rather than drawing
this wire here,
I often times draw a ground
here and simply throw ground
wherever I want.
This symbol simply refers to
the fact that the other terminal
is taken at the ground node.
So here is my V nought.
Now, let's go and analyze this
and see what it gives us.
In this example,
V1 and V2 may be outputs of two
sensors, maybe heat sensors or
something like that.
This is a heat sensor on that
side of the room and this is a
heat sensor on this side of the
room.
And I pass their signals
through two resistors and I look
at the voltage there.
So by now you should be able to
write the answer V nought,
or the value V nought almost by
inspection.
Just to show you,
let me use superposition.
When you see multiple sources,
the first thing you should
think about is can I use
superposition to simplify my
life?
And let me do that.
V nought here is the sum of two
voltages, one due to V1 acting
alone and one due to V2 acting
alone.
So what's the voltage here due
to V1 acting alone?
To find out that I short this
voltage, I zero out this voltage
and look at the effect of V1.
So the effect of V1,
if this were shorted out,
is simply V1 x R2 / R1 + R2.
This is now a voltage divider,
right?
A voltage V applied across two
resistors and the output taken
across one resistor.
So that's this value.
Then I could do the second
part.
To look at the effect of V2,
what I will do is short this
voltage and look at the effect
of this.
Now, this voltage is across
this resistor divider.
And so I get R1 / (R1 + R2)
here.
So you'll notice that for
something like this,
if I had applied KVL and KCL of
the node method I would have
gotten a bunch of equations,
but here I wrote it just by
inspection.
You should be able to look at
circuit patterns like this and
write the answers down very
quickly.
Let's say if I chose R1 to be
equal to R2 then V nought would
simply be (V1 + V2) / 2.
So if these two values were
equal, I simply get the output,
the average of the two
voltages.
So this guy is an adder
circuit.
It adds up these two voltages.
But more precisely it's an
averaging circuit.
It takes two voltages and gives
me the average value.
Now, if you have two sensors in
the room, you might think of why
you want to take that average
value to control the temperature
of the room.
But suffice it to say that V
nought is the average of the two
values.
So let me show you a quick demo
of this example and then look at
what the problems are with this
example.
So let's say,
as one example,
I applied a square wave at V1,
which is the top curve,
the green curve,
and I applied a triangular wave
at V2, that's the second one.
As you expect,
the output is going to be the
sum of the two voltages scaled
appropriately.
So notice that I have a square
wave with a superimposed
triangular wave on top.
And I can play around.
What I could do is change the
amplitude of my wave form here.
And, as you notice,
the amplitude of the output
component also changes
accordingly.
So this is one simple example
of an adder circuit,
and the two wave forms get
summed up and I get the output.
So I'll switch to Page 3.
Let me just draw a little
sketch for you here.
Here, what I showed you was I
had a triangular wave coming on
one of these inputs and I had a
square wave on the other one,
and the output looks something
like this.
OK?
No surprise here.
This is a simple analog signal
processing circuit which gives
me the average of two wave
forms.
Now, let me do the following.
Often times I may need to look
at this value some distance
away.
So let's say this person here
wants to look at the value.
So I bring this wire here.
And I also bring the ground
connection and I look at it.
I look at this value here.
And when I have a long wire I
can get noise added onto the
circuit.
So let's say a bunch of noise
gets added into the signal
there.
And what I end up seeing here
is not something that looks like
this but something that looks
like that.
That's not unusual.
And the problem with this is
now when I look at this,
if I'm looking to distinguish
between, say,
a 3.9 and a 3.8,
it's really hard to do that
because my noise is overwhelming
my signal.
I have a real problem,
a real problem here.
Noise is a fact of life.
So what do we do?
This is so fundamental.
Large bodies of courses in
electrical engineering are
devoted to how do I carefully
analyze signals in the presence
of noise?
You'll take courses in speech
processing that look at clever
techniques to recognize speech
in the presence of noise and so
on and so forth.
One technique we adopt that
we'll talk about here,
which is fundamental to EECS,
is using the digital
abstraction.
Let me show you how it can
really help with the noise
problem.
So the idea is value lumping or
value discretization.
Much like we lumped matter,
we've discretized matter into
discrete chunks,
let's discretize value into two
chunks.
Let's simply say that now I'm
going to deal with two values
and I can, say,
call them high,
low.
I have a bunch of choices here.
I may call it 5 volts and 0
volts.
I may call it true and false.
What I'm doing is I'm just
restricting my universe to deal
with just two values,
zero and one.
This is like dealing with a
number system with only two
digits.
And these are zero and one.
So what I've now done is I'm
saying that rather than dealing
with all possible continuous
values, 0.1, 3.9999 recurring
and so on and so forth,
what I'm going to do is simply
deal with a high and a low.
Dealing with this whole
continuum of numbers is really
complicated.
Let me simplify my life and
just postulate that I am going
to be looking at high and low.
Whenever I see something I'll
look at it and say high or low,
is it black or white,
period.
There's no choice here,
just two individual values.
So that sounds simple,
and nice and so on,
but what's the point?
What do we get by doing that?
Let's take our example.
Let's take what might be a
digital system.
Let's take a digital system and
let's say I have a sender.
Much like I sent a signal value
a long distance,
let me have a sender,
and I have a ground as well and
here is a receiver.
This symbol simply says that
both of them share a ground
wire.
So the sender and a receiver.
And what I'm interested in
doing, the sender is interested
in sending a signal to the
receiver.
And in the digital system,
the way I would send a digital
signal is all I can use is ones
and zeros, OK?
So let's say the sender sends
something like this.
The sender wants to send a
value.
This is my time axis and this
is 2.5 volts,
this is 0 volts and this is 5
volts.
My sender has some agreement
with the receiver and says I'm
just going to be sending to you
low values and high values.
And this signal here would
correspond to "0" "1" "0".
It's a symbol.
That's why I have input zero in
quotes there.
We'll go into this in much more
detail later,
but for now suffice it to say
that I'm sending a set of
signals here "0" "1" "0".
This simplistic scheme will not
work in many situations but go
along with this for a few
seconds.
So I send the signal sequence
"0" "1" "0" out here.
And notice that there is a high
and a low.
And the agreement the sender
and the receiver have is that,
look, if you see a value that's
higher than 2.5 volts that's a
high.
If you see a value below 2.5
volts in the wire that's a low.
And I'm going to send a 0 volt
and a 5 volt from here.
So now at the sending site
let's say I don't have any noise
in this system.
Let's say this is my Vn,
some noise being added.
And let's say Vn is 0.
Then in that case I will
receive exactly what is sent "0"
"0" 5, 2.5, 0 volts.
And this is time.
Nothing fancy here,
right?
My receiver receives a "0" "1"
"0".
Now, the beauty of this is that
now suppose I were to impose
noise much like I had noise out
there and Vn was not 0.
Rather Vn was some noise
voltage, let's say 0.2 volts
peak to peak.
Let's say that simply got
superposed on the signal.
In which case what do I get?
What I end up here with is a
signal that looks like this.
So the receiver gets that
signal because a noise is added
into my signal and that's what I
get.
But guess what?
No problem.
The receiver says oh,
yeah, this is a 0 because the
values are less than 2.5,
this is a 1 and this is a 0.
"0" "1" "0".
So here my receiver was able to
receive the signal and correctly
interpret it without any
problems.
So because I used this value
discretization and because I had
this agreement with the
receiver, I had better noise
immunity.
Consequently,
I had what is called a noise
margin.
Noise margin says how much
noise can I tolerate?
And in this situation,
because the sender sends 5
volts and 0 volts,
the 5 volts can creep all the
way down to 2.5,
I'll still be OK.
Similarly, 0 could go all the
way up to 2.5,
I'd still be OK.
So in this case I have a noise
margin of 2.5 volts for a 1 and
similarly 2.5 volts for a 0,
because there are 2.5 volts
between a 0 volt and 2.5.
So notice that I have a nice
little noise margin here,
which simply is the English
meaning of the term there is a
margin for noise.
And even though I can change
the signal value by up to 2.5
volts, the receiver will still
correctly interpret the signal.
So I've decided to discretize
values into highs and lows.
And because of that,
if all I wanted to do in life
is send highs and lows I can
send them very effectively.
There are many complications,
but if all I care about is
sending highs and lows I can
send it with a lot of tolerance
to noise.
So many of you are saying but
what about this,
but what about that?
There are lots of buts here.
And let's take a look at some
of them.
If you look up there.
What I ended up doing was
creating a design space that
looked like this.
This is on Page 6.
What I did was I said with a
range of values from 0 to 5,
what I'm going to do is at 2.5
I drew a line and I said as a
sender if you wanted to send a 0
then you would send a value
here.
And if you wanted to send a 1
you would send a value here.
Similarly, for a receiver.
And if the sender sent a value
all the way up in 5 volts that
was the best thing,
but technically the sender
could send any value between 2.5
and 5.
And if there was no noise then
the receiver could correctly
interpret a 1 if it was above
this and 0 if it was below this.
The problem with this approach
really is that if I allow the
sender to send any value above
2.5 all the way to 5 then there
really is no noise margin in
this situation.
OK?
Because if I allowed the sender
to send any value between 2.5
and 5 then what if I have a
value 2.5 for a 1?
Then I may end up getting very
little noise margin on the other
side.
Worse yet, what if I get a
value 2.5?
That's a much worse situation.
What if the receiver receives a
value of 2.5?
Now what?
What does the receiver do?
The receiver cannot tell
whether it's a 1 or a 0.
The receiver gets hopelessly
confused.
So to deal with that,
I'm going to fix this,
what I'm going to do is the
following.
Switch to Page 7.
What I'll do here is to prevent
the receiver from getting
confused, if the receiver saw
2.5, what I'm going to do is
define what is called "no man's
land".
I'm going to define the region
of my voltage space called the
forbidden region.
And what I'm going to do is,
say, let's say I defined it as
2 volts, 3 volts and 5 volts,
0, 2, 3 and 5.
With my forbidden region,
if I have a sender then I tell
the sender you can send any
value between 3 and 5 for a 1.
And you can send any value
between 2 and 0 for a 0.
To send the symbol 0,
I can send any voltage between
0 and 2, and similarly for 1.
At the receiving side,
if I see any value between 3
and 5, I read that as a 0,
and any value between 0 and 2 I
read that as 2 volts.
So I may label this value VH
and label this threshold VL,
so there's a high threshold and
a low threshold.
So this solves one problem.
Now the receiver can never see
a value in the forbidden region.
Now, I can stand her and
pontificate and say,
oops, that's a forbidden
region, thou shalt not go there.
But what if I get some noise
and a value goes in there?
In real systems values may
enter there.
But what I'm saying,
so this is the beauty of using
a discipline.
Let me use my playground
analogy.
This is my playground.
We got into this playground
using the discrete matter of
discipline, the playground of
EECS, but in that playground
some region of that playground
deals with just high and low
values.
I further restrict the
playground and I say I'm only
going to focus on that
playground in which all signal
values have a forbidden region.
All senders and receivers
adhere to a forbidden region.
And if there is any signal in
this space, in the forbidden
space then my behavior is
undefined.
I don't care.
You want to go there?
Sure.
I don't know what's going to
happen to you.
Now, we're engineers,
right?
So we've disciplined ourselves
to play in this playground.
It's like I tell my 9-year-old,
don't go there,
right?
And of course he wants to go
there.
He says what will happen if I
go there?
And the answer here will be
undefined, OK?
Something really bad could
happen to you.
I don't know what it is but
something really bad,
you know, a lightening bolt or
who knows what,
but something really bad.
And you as a designer of a
circuit can, let's say you were
Intel.
Intel designs its chips.
And let's say Intel decides to
play in this playground and
there is a forbidden region.
So Intel says oh,
it's really easy for me if in
the forbidden region the chip
simply burns up and catches
fire, we'll sell more chips.
That's fine.
Whatever you want.
The key here is that all I'm
saying is that I am going to
discipline myself into playing
in this playground and that's
where I will define my rules,
and you stay within the
boundaries and all the rules
will apply.
It's called a "discipline."
You're disciplining yourselves
to stay within it.
There's no logic to it.
It's just a discipline.
Just do it and you'll be OK.
When we look at practical
circuits and so on,
we have to address the issue of
what happens when things go in
there.
But let's postpone that
discussion.
For now I've solved one of my
problems, which is,
the previous problem was what
does a receiver do if it saw a
2.5?
Now it can't see a 2.5.
But then the receiver asks,
Agarwal, but what if I see a
2.5?
I can tell the receiver you can
do whatever you want to do.
You can stomp it.
You can squish it.
You can burn it.
You can chuck it.
Whatever you want.
It's up to you.
Do whatever you want.
You won't see a value.
If you do, do whatever you
want.
It's undefined.
That works.
So you, as the receiver
designer can do whatever you
want when you see a 2.5.
You can say yeah,
I'll just put out a 1 if I see
a 2.5 or a 2.6.
I'll just do something.
No one cares.
So this is pretty good.
This is pretty good.
We still have a problem,
though.
Do people see the problem here?
This still doesn't quite work.
If Intel did this,
instead of your laptops failing
and blue-screening every hour
they'd be doing it every
millisecond.
So the problem is this
discipline have allowed the
sender to send any value between
3 and 5 as a 1.
And any value between 3 and 5
at the receiver is treated as a
Do you see where the problem
is?
Yes?
The sender sends a 1.99 and the
noise pumps it into forbidden
region.
Exactly.
So the sender says it's
legitimate, I'm Intel.
They've told me stick to 0 and
And Intel parts will be sending
to values between 0 and 2.
And Motorola parts,
which are receivers,
you know they have to receive 0
and 2.
So Intel can send the value,
They can because it's 1.9 out
of 2.
It's legal.
This way I can make really
cheap parts.
But now the problem is that
even the smallest amount of
noise will bump it into the
forbidden region,
and so therefore this one has a
problem.
And the problem is that this
one offers zero noise margin.
There is no noise margin.
There is no margin for noise in
the discipline.
All right, back to the drawing
board, folks.
Switch to Page 8.
Let's get rid of all this stuff
and go back to the drawing
board.
OK, so what do we do now?
How about the following?
How, about as before I say,
as a receiver,
if you see a value between 3
and 5 you treat that as a 1 and
a value between 0 and 2 you
treat that as a 0.
No difference.
So as a receiver same as
before.
But now what I do is I hold the
sender to tougher standards.
I hold the feet of the sender
to the fire and say you have to
adhere to tougher standards.
So what I'm going to do is hold
the sender to tougher standards,
maybe four walls.
That is tell the sender that if
you want to send to 0 or a 1,
for a 1 you have to send a
value between 4 and 5,
and for a 0 a value between 0
and 1.
Sender is now held to tougher
standards.
This is what my chart looks
like.
So now I do have some noise
margin.
Can someone tell me what is the
noise margin here for a 1?
1 volt.
And the reason is that the
lowest voltage a sender can send
is 4 volts, OK?
If the 4 leaks down to 2.99
that's in the forbidden region,
I'm in trouble.
This is my forbidden region
here.
And 2.99 is in the forbidden
region.
I'm in trouble.
So notice that the lowest value
that the receiver can receive is
3 volts.
So if I sent the 4 and sent
this over a long cable to you,
the value can be beaten up by
noise to such an extent that you
may begin receiving 3s but
nothing lower than a 3.
So this is a noise margin,
1 volt.
Similarly, for a 0 the noise
margin is also 1 volt.
So let me label these.
There are four important
thresholds here.
This threshold is called VOL.
V output low.
These have special meanings.
This threshold here is called
VOH, V output high.
This threshold here is called V
input high and this threshold
here is called V input low.
So VOH simply says that senders
must send voltages higher than
VOH.
Receivers must receive values
higher than VIH as a 1.
So these four thresholds
together give you your
threshold.
For the sender gets 2.5,
what does sender do?
It could do that.
So, in that case,
you can do that.
If all you want to do is have
one value here then what you
have is an infinitesimal value
here for the forbidden region.
That's fine.
It's up to you to design it
that way.
You can.
But it turns out that when you
design circuits,
when we see some examples in
the next lecture it turns out to
be fairly practical and easy to
do it this way.
But, again, these are design
choices.
If I'm Intel,
Intel wants all its parts to
work together.
So parts that follow a common
discipline can work together,
right?
Because senders will send
values, receivers will receive
these values here,
so it will simply work.
So the noise margin for a 1
here is simply VOH minus VIH and
the noise margin for a 0 is VIL
minus VOL.
VIL minus VOL is the noise
margin for a 0.
So what do we have here?
What we have here is a
discipline that we've agreed to
follow where senders are held to
a tough standard and receivers
are held to a different standard
so that I allow myself some
margin for error.
And it's up to you as a
designer to choose ranges for
the forbidden region.
Now, you may say that I want to
make my forbidden region as
small as possible.
But you will see in practical
circuits it's very hard to
achieve that.
Practical devices that you get,
they have a natural region that
gets very, very hard to break
apart, and that tends to
establish what that region looks
like.
So to continue with an example
here, I may have the following
voltage wave form for a sender.
So I have some sender,
I have a sender here.
I have VOL, VIL,
VIH, VOH and some other high
voltage.
And then, as a sender,
if I want to send a "0" "1" "0"
then I send a 0.
I have to be within this band.
And then for a 1 I have to be
within this band.
So this is an example of,
say, "0" "1" "0" "1".
And at the receiver --
Let's have VOL,
VIL, VIH, VOH.
So at the receiver,
I interpret any signal below
VIL as a 0.
So I may get some signal that
looks like this.
And I'll still interpret that
as a "0" "1" "0" "1".
So to summarize here,
this discipline that forms the
foundations of digital systems
is called "a static discipline".
The static discipline says if
inputs meet input thresholds --
So if an input to a digital
system meets the input
thresholds then outputs will
meet, or the digital system
should ensure that the outputs
--
Output thresholds.
So this means that if I have a
system like this then if I give
it good inputs.
And by giving it good inputs I
mean for 1s I have signal values
that are greater than VIH and
for 0s signal values which are
less than VIL.
These are valid inputs.
So if my inputs are valid,
that is below VIL for a 0 and
above VIH for a 1 then this
digital system D will produce
corresponding outputs that
follow output thresholds.
For a 1 it will produce outputs
that are greater than VOH and if
it needs to produce a 0 it will
produce outputs that are less
than VOL.
So notice that there is this
tough requirement in digital
systems that for the inputs,
I should recognize as a 1
anything higher than a VIH.
But if I want to produce a 1,
I have to produce a tough 1
like a 4-volt 1.
So there is a discipline that
all my digital systems must
follow, and that discipline is
called a static discipline.
So static discipline encodes
the thresholds,
encodes four thresholds that
all digital systems must follow
so that they can talk to each
other.
So if Intel and Motorola want
to make parts that are
compatible with,
say, Pentium 4 devices then
they will all talk over the
phone or something and agree on
a static discipline.
We will say that,
all right, all my peripherals
will follow a static discipline
with the following volted
thresholds.
And this way parts made by
different manufacturers can
interoperate and still provide
immunity to noise.
Yes.
Question?
Absolutely.
There are many constraints on
how you as a designer choose the
noise margin.
As a designer you want to make
your noise margin as large as
possible.
The larger the noise margin the
better you can tolerate noise
which is why,
how many people have heard of
some devices called rad hard
devices, radiation hard devices?
Some of you have.
There are a bunch of devices.
Different manufacturers make
different kinds of devices for
different markets.
For consumer markets they use
parts which may have relatively
poor noise margins because
consumers can tolerate more
faults.
But if you're building devices
for, say, the medical industry
or for spaceships and so on,
you need to be held to a much,
much tougher standard.
So for those devices you may
end up having much,
much tighter bands in which you
have to operate so you have a
tougher noise margin.
So that leads us to,
given these sort of voltage
thresholds, we now move into the
digital world.
And in the digital world we can
build a bunch of digital
devices.
The first device we will look
at is called a combinational
gate.
A combinational gate is a
device that adheres to the
static discipline,
Page 11, and this is a device
whose outputs are a function of
inputs alone.
So I can build little boxes
which take some inputs,
produces an output where the
outputs are a function of the
existing inputs.
And this kind of a device is
called a combinational gate.
And I can analyze such devices
for the kinds of things that I
would like to do.
Before I go into the kinds of
devices I'd like to build,
let's spend a few minutes
talking about how to process
signals.
How to process digital signals,
Page 10.
So notice that you have two
values, 0 and a 1.
So devices like my
combinational gate,
for example,
can only deal with 0s and 1s.
So I have to come up with some
kind of a mathematics or some
kind of a set of processing that
can work with 0,1 values.
So 0,1 map completely natural
to the logic true and false.
So I can borrow from logic and
use true and false to do my
processing of signals.
So if all I care about is
processing logic values,
0s and 1s, trues and falses
then that's all I need.
I can also use numbers.
How do I represent a number?
3.9 which is 0s and 1s.
It turns out that this is a
whole field in itself.
You'll hear more about this in
recitation.
Let me also point you to the
last section of the course
notes, Chapter 5.6 I believe,
that talks about how to
represent numbers.
The basic insight is much like
you can represent arbitrary long
numbers with the digits 0
through 9 in the same way,
but concatenating digits you
can represent arbitrary long
numbers with 0-1-1-1-0-0 and so
on.
So you can have a whole
sequence of digits and you can
build a binary number system.
So you can read A&L Section
5.6, I believe.
It's the last section for
numbers.
And you will also discuss this
in your recitation tomorrow.
Let me spend some more time
talking about Boolean logic,
two-valued logic,
and how to process these
systems.
So one way of processing it is
using logic statements of the
following form.
If X is true and Y is true then
Z is true, else is Z false.
So this is a logic statement.
It says if X is true and Y is
true then Z is true,
else Z is false.
So I can process this with 0s
and 1s, trues and falses.
And I do this all the time so I
have a succinct notation for
this.
I express this as Z is X anded
with Y.
X and Y is Z.
So Z is true if X is true and Y
is true.
A shorthand notation for this
is just a dot.
And a circuit notation for this
is called an "AND gate".
That's a little circuit.
I haven't told you what's
inside it.
It's an abstract little device
called an AND gate which takes
two inputs, produces one output
Z where the output is related to
the inputs in the following
manner.
That's a little device called
an AND gate.
I could also represent logic in
truth tables.
And truth tables simply
enumerate all the values and the
corresponding outputs.
Inputs can be 0-0-0-1-1-0 or
1-1.
For an AND system output is 1,
only if both are ones,
it's a 0 otherwise.
So that's a truth table for AND
gate.
So from 0s and 1s we deal with
logic and we create devices like
the AND gate to process digital
signals.
And what we will do is look at
a whole bunch of little symbols
like this, like the AND gate to
process our input signals.
And these devices might look
like other functions like OR
gates and so on.
Let me show you a quick demo.
What I'm going to show you is a
signal feeding an AND gate.
And one signal is going to look
like this, and my signal Y is
going to look like this.
So you expect a processed
output.
So 1-0-1-0-1-0-1.
And the output is simply going
to be --
This is my time axis going this
way.
It is going to be an AND-ing of
these two signal values like so.
What I'm also going to show you
is I'm going to superimpose
noise on this wire.
I'm going to superimpose noise
on the wire, and what I want you
to observe is the output of this
digital gate.
The output will stay exactly
like this, even though I impose
noise.
The ultimate test.
So stay right there.
Let's do this demo.
Give me a couple of seconds.
If you look at the signal up
there, look at the middle wave
form, and I'm imposing let's
have a digital system in a noisy
environment like a lumberyard,
for example,
or chopping a bunch of trees in
my backyard and building digital
systems on the side.
And if I have my buddies
revving up chainsaws
superimposing noise on my second
input, but look at the output.
And just to show that I'm not
bluffing here,
what I'll do is I'll pass the
noise through and make the noise
larger.
And you'll notice that when the
noise begins to surpass the
noise margins the output begins
to go berserk.
Watch.
Can you increase it gradually?
Notice that as I put in a lot
more noise then the output
begins to go berserk,
but as long as my input is
within the noise margin my
output stays perfectly stable.
So that's the "Intro to Digital
Systems".
You'll see numbers in
recitation.
And we'll see you at lecture on
Tuesday.